hello everyone i'm james murphy and
welcome to emcoding where we try to get
a little better at programming each
episode so that we can ultimately
determine whether or not we're in the
matrix in today's episode what are
python's future imports while they look
like normal import statements they're
anything but
this video is sponsored by me thank you
to me for sponsoring myself did you know
that i'm available for python and c plus
consulting contracting training and
interview prep services again let's give
a round of applause to me for sponsoring
myself this is the future module it's a
real module but it doesn't really do
anything it defines some constants and
it has a class that represents some
metadata and then it just has a bunch of
metadata about the future features but
beyond just keeping track of this
metadata the code in this file at least
doesn't implement any of those features
what actually happens is python looks
for these future imports whenever it
compiles a module and then sets a
specific feature flag depending on which
future imports you used
for instance if we from future import
annotations then this co-future
annotations flag will be set in the
compiler
let's take a look at the c code that
this actually affects during compilation
i know compared to python this might
look very verbose but i promise you
don't need to know any c in order to
understand this
this is the function that gets called to
convert an annotation in an argument
into bytecode
the important part is right here we have
a set of features represented by a bunch
of bit flags and we do a bitwise and
with the feature flag that we're
interested in in this case co-future
annotations
if the feature flag is set we use this
visit macro which just expands to
calling this function
the bytecode operation this corresponds
to is then loading a new constant the
constant that we load is the annotation
expression as unicode
i.e treat the annotation as a string
let's see that in action
here we have a node class with an
annotation for its data member we can
access the annotations at runtime like
this
notice that what gets printed out is
that the annotation has the string int
in it but if we comment out the future
import then we see the annotation
contains the actual int class object so
a future import is doing something
really fundamental it's completely
changing the way that python interprets
your source code it can literally cause
python to generate different bytecode
and therefore completely change the
meaning of your program so what are all
of these future imports and why are they
used instead of just telling a user to
upgrade to the next version after all if
i have a new feature like the match
statement from python 3.10 it's easy to
tell people if you want to use the match
statement you need to upgrade to 310
but if you were already using
annotations in a previous version
upgrading and changing the behavior can
break old code
we don't want to go around just breaking
people's old code for no reason we need
a really good reason if we're going to
do something like that
and this is where python might differ
from some languages like c and c plus
plus
in c plus plus backwards compatibility
is a much stronger priority than in
python a broken incomplete or not well
thought out feature might very well stay
in the language forever
in python you get about three to five
years to upgrade and the way that you
opt into an upgrade early is by using a
future import
so why do we need a future import for
annotations what's wrong just sticking
the class object in there
well if an annotation is just treated
like a normal expression that implies
that the annotation should be defined
before the thing that it's annotating
this makes it impossible to define a
recursive data structure like a linked
list when i try to annotate the next
pointer in the linked list i'm in the
process of defining the node class so
the node class is not defined yet and
hence i get a name error the annoying
solution to this is to put quotes around
your annotations and then hope that your
editor and your type checker understand
as we already saw the future solution to
this is to just automatically always
treat annotations as strings
very few programs actually care to
access type ins at runtime but those
that do can use typing.gettypins to
evaluate the strings back into class
objects or whatever eventually the
behavior of the future import will just
become the default behavior
but do keep in mind that with future
imports the behavior is not always
completely settled
when you opt in early to a feature it's
possible that that will change before
the feature actually comes out in fact
with annotations specifically there's a
decent chance this behavior will just be
replaced by some kind of lazy computing
of the annotations that's definitely
something to watch out for but i don't
really worry about it and in fact i use
this particular future import in almost
every file that i define so what are all
the rest of the future imports
when in doubt of course go to the source
the good news since these are breaking
changes after all is that there are only
two that even apply to python 3. this
one is just an easter egg as you can see
it's set to appear in python 4.
all the rest are in python 2. unicode
literals allowed you to create bytes
literals like this using the b and then
quotes print function introduced the
print function
with statement introduced the with
statement
absolute import changed and clarified
the way that absolute and relative
imports work
division made the single slash always
mean float division and introduced the
double slash to mean int division
generators introduced generators
and nested scopes allow the ability to
define nested scopes and guaranteed that
they would be computed at compile time
in particular this allowed for lambdas
or inner functions to access variables
that were defined inside another
enclosing function scope and that's all
the future imports except for one which
is generator stop
generator stop was introduced because of
the following behavior
we want the generator to yield one two
three four
pretend one two three and four are just
stand-ins for some complex operations
maybe two and three are particularly
complicated to compute so we factor it
out into a subgenerator
but we made a mistake in our
subgenerator we're only yielding one
thing instead of two things before we're
done however we have two unguarded calls
to next the first call works as normal
and returns two then for the second call
we hit the return which raises a stop
iteration
so what's effectively happening is a
stop iteration is getting raised at this
point in the generator
we're not inside a loop we made a call
to next and we got an exception which is
propagating up but nothing's shown to
the user that's because because we're in
a generator that stop iteration gets
raised all the way up to this for loop
and normally when a for loop receives a
stop iteration that means we're just
done iterating so the program prints out
one two and then stops
instead of raising the exception and
showing the user an error message we
silently loop over less data than we
intended to
so i really don't want stop iterations
and generators to cause for loops to
just terminate if i wanted a for loop to
just terminate i can always just return
from the function which will end up
raising a stop iteration in the for loop
but having an unhandled stop iteration
propagate outside a generator is almost
always a bug
so from future import generator stop and
now any stop iteration that's raised out
of a generator gets turned into a
runtime error
no more silent errors we get a big
beautiful error message telling us
exactly where things went wrong the
future import allowed us starting in
python 3.5 to opt in to this new
behavior
but hopefully you or your company are
now using a version of python that's at
least three seven it's fine to leave the
future import in it doesn't hurt
anything but as of 37 you can delete it
and that's now the default behavior
so realistically the only one that you
really need to worry about is from
future import annotations
and quick tip that you might not have
realized since annotations are now just
strings i can actually start using
typing features from way later versions
for instance this bar notation for the
union of types was introduced in python
310 but it's working just fine in three
seven
this works completely fine as long as
you're not trying to actually evaluate
those annotations at runtime
if you're doing that then you just need
to upgrade
actually if you dig into the c source
code there's one more future import you
might be interested in
anyway that's all i've got and finally i
want to give a huge shout out to neil
rashania thank you to neil for
subscribing at the factorial level on
patreon
i really appreciate the support of
course thank you to the rest of my
patrons as well
don't forget to subscribe leave a
comment and as always slap that like
button an odd number of times see you
next time